[Music]
so for the past
15 years we've been hosting diversity
and leadership
it's taken a couple of different forms
it's had a couple of different names
over time
but the spirit has always been the same
it's always been about
how can we help people from all
backgrounds see themselves
in business school and more specifically
here at the gsb
this is an incredible place where we
hope to help
you achieve your dreams and so to kick
us off today
there we have a couple of really special
guests um and to start us
off is someone who uh we have the honor
of guiding us through these turbulent
times as a school
so i don't think he knows this but
within the first couple months of me
being here
he said something that has really shaped
the way i approach
education said
education is fundamentally about
encountering
difference education about encountering
difference
sit with that whether it's a new formula
maybe it's a framework
uh a new philosophy or even listening to
the lived experience of someone very
different from yourself
these are different ways to see the
world with new lenses and approach
things from new directions
this is where learning and growth comes
and that's bringing us to today
diversity and leadership is about
celebrating the different perspectives
that you're going to encounter
in your everyday life at the gsb and in
your career beyond
and so with that i turn it over to the
captain of our ship
someone who again has been really
influential on the way i view this work
the one the only dean of the stanford
graduate school of business
john levin thank you will
and um welcome everyone
to this event it's just such a pleasure
for us to get to host you
uh for uh for an entire the entire week
of diversity and leadership we've got so
many good things coming up this week so
i'm really excited for everyone who's
gonna who's gonna be part of this and
and for all the the faculty and the
students and the staff
uh who've participated to bring this
week together
as will said this week is really an
opportunity you know for
for all of you who are interested
thinking about an mba degree
to to hear from
our community about diversity inclusion
here at stanford in the workplace and
beyond and about its role
in mba education and
here at stanford we we set out several
years ago to make
diversity and equity inclusion a major
priority at the school
and and that's involved a whole bunch of
different efforts
to first increase representation in our
mba class and
in our other educational programs as
well and and on our faculty
second to make the school just generally
a more inclusive and welcoming
place and that you know that you know
incre in curriculum decisions
in our speakers in campus activities and
in the
culture of the school and and here i
think you're gonna you'll see it this
week but that you know that
in the culture was really building on
what was already a very strong sense of
belonging and community
that exists at stamford and and many
many
years and hundreds and thousands of
people who've been at the school have
have gone into
building that foundation and then third
the view that we wanted to have an
impact on business leadership
and business practices that extend well
beyond our campus
and we do that through programs for
alumni for companies for entrepreneurs
investors and through the work
and careers of our own students who come
to the school and then
graduate having you know absorbed and
uh the skills and the the thinking and
the at a can-do attitude that sort of
permeates this place
before they they go off to to do amazing
things in the world
this year and i think you're going to
hear a lot about it this week we've put
a
a really special focus on issues of
racial equity
we put out a action plan for racial i
could do this summer
that was the product of work by uh of
students and and faculty and staff and
hundreds of alumni
uh who after the events of last spring
and the black lives matter protests
really felt a need to
get engaged at stanford and to work
together
to see what we could do to help move the
country
forward from the difficult period we we
went through
last spring and many ways continue to go
through today
so we've been very focused on executing
that plan this year and i think you'll
get to hear
quite a lot about some of those efforts
over the over the coming week and i'm
really excited
about the progress we've already been
making
i'm just going to finish by saying that
as we've thought about
diversity and inclusion at the gsb
there's several principles that we've
tried to keep in mind and i thought i'd
just share them we'll actually already
alluded to one of them but i'm going to
mention three
the first is uh the first is a
conviction that
every successful leader today no matter
whether you're
here in the u.s or here in silicon
valley where we are or anywhere in the
country or anywhere around the world
it is just a mission critical skill
to be able to assemble and work with and
get the most out of
diverse talent and that's not an easy
skill
actually to to to master it's hard to
bring people together
from from different backgrounds and with
different views i mean just look at the
challenge of leading this country today
it's not so easy to bring people
together
but it is something that anyone who
wants to go on to be successful in a
leadership position
has to think about and has to try to get
better at and that's you know that's
hard work and that's when we
we really focus on a lot in in our
teaching here
and in the in the way we do management
education
the second principle which which will
already mentioned is
is an understanding that as will just
said
before that that education itself is
about encountering difference and here
you know as well said
education is about encountering
different people
different cultures and different ideas
and so and that is a sense in which
diversity itself
is just intrinsically tied up with
educational excellence
i think that's it's a really important
point to keep in mind sometimes people
express these things as if they were
intention
or they were counter points to one
another but actually they're not
they're intrinsically connected that
having different points of view
is the way we learn and so that's a
really important thing to keep in mind
at every educational institution we
don't want to ever lose sight
of that and then the last principle we
try to keep in mind is that
just a belief that the gsb and stanford
and those of us who are who are part of
this place
have a responsibility to help make the
world
a place of broader and more equal
opportunity
and that you know comes about through
individual efforts and through our
collective efforts and
i think those beliefs those principles
have been you know what
have really helped to bring our
community students
and faculty and staff and alumni
together
around diversity inclusion and i'm i'm
so excited that all of you are going to
get a chance this week to
to be part of it uh and to sort of see
some of our thinking and we're going to
get to learn from you
and you know hope we'll down the road
see some of you on our campuses as
students so welcome and thanks for being
here and
i hope the week is fantastic
okay now i have the really great
pleasure of introducing
the the high points of this session who
are our our two student association
presidents uh cario miguel and emily
clawkins
and i i won't give them long interest
i'll just say that um
carrie and emily are so they were
elected as uh as co-presidents of our
student association their nba twos
and they were elected in uh and took
office
in march of 2020 which was
uh a difficult time to ascend to a
leadership position
on a on a campus and
have been amazing they are they have
really
shown just truly extraordinary
student leadership in a way that i think
probably a few students have had the
opportunity to
to get to show because they've they've
had to lead the the student body
through the pandemic in a very difficult
period in time and just in every way
have modeled a wonderful
you know wonderful run for leadership i
i i'm going to be so sorry to lose them
at the end of this year
but i cannot wait to see what they
accomplish out in the world so they've
been
and they've been incredible champions
for diversity inclusion so i'm going to
turn it over to carrie and emily to
kick things off thank you so much dean
levin for those kind words
and welcome everyone i think it might be
helpful to kick this off by sharing with
you all how i see diversity coming to
life on campus
and a few things that emily and i are
looking forward to as co-presidents this
year
prior to coming to the gsb there were
moments where i chose to
sort of minimize or adapt my identity in
an effort to mimic
leadership models i had been exposed to
but one thing i've learned
over the course of my time at the gsb is
that you cannot separate the human
from the leader i am my authentic self
when i bring all my identities
being a black man being born in nigeria
attending a state school in texas having
a non-traditional pre-gsb career in oil
and gas just to name a few
this means that while i still frequently
enter rooms real and virtual
full of people who may not look like me
or identify with my lived experiences
the gsb provides me and so many others a
platform
to embrace our identities as part of how
we choose to lead
from experiential classes dedicated to
answering the question
why would anyone follow you to
collaboration with classmates from all
walks of life
i found that the gsb provides many
avenues for finding and showcasing the
diversity of thought
backgrounds and leadership styles of all
members of our community
the next point of our differences coming
together and being celebrated is truly
where the magic happens
both inside and outside of the classroom
but with that said
our goals as essay co-presidents and our
students have crystallized in the
context of
all that 2020 has brought for us
grounding us
in what truly matters most we're looking
forward to continuing to serve the gsb
community and collaborating with student
leaders and the administration to push
forward
some of those important initiatives dean
evan mentioned including
gsb's racial equity plan designing safe
hybrid learning environments
launching student and staff recognition
programs and also trying to reduce
financial burdens
just to name a few in closing as you go
through this week of programming
i would like you to reflect on the fact
that although many of the environments
we occupy
are not perfect there is power in
courageously stepping into
uncomfortable and uncharted spaces and
making them better than how we found
them
i urge each and every one of you to
bring your full selves
and to see your identities as your
superpowers
we hope that you will one day soon join
us in leaving a lasting legacy
of positive impact on the gsb community
and the world
welcome again and i'll hand it over to
emily
thanks gary uh it is a central joy and
also the most intimidating thing ever
to speak after carrie has already spoken
because he is so exceptional
um but i just wanted to say something
people talk about a lot
is that business school is an investment
in yourself and i think in this way
there's a lot of
hope and faith placed in this place gsb
to transform us to to empower us and to
deliver
on that promise to deliver on that value
i
would see this place as totally fueled
by optimism
and a willingness to improve and to be
changed and to grow
and in that way i think that the gsb is
one of the best classrooms in the world
to learn this skill set and to empower
yourself to engage with difference and
to bring the best out of diverse teams
exactly as dean levin said um and as
kerry has already mentioned
most of like our proudest moments as
students um here at the gsb for
a little over a year but also as people
who have been on this earth for
25 plus years have happened in the last
six months
i think the opportunity to build to have
hard conversations
and to shift how people experience the
gsb is like a central privilege of my
life and of carrie's life
and it's been phenomenally important for
us um
i also think a level of this that's
important is that in my view our
generation
joins uh companies and purchases from
companies
that they believe they feel a sense of
connection to based on how those
companies
express social missions and move through
what is an incredibly
tense and important time in the world
and because of that
i think there's really few skill sets
more important
than graduating from the gsb ready to
lead a company
in a way where you're prepared to issue
a press release about how you feel about
what happened to the summer
where you're prepared to signal to your
customers and your employees that you
care and that you see them and that you
find what they face important
and central to the way you're running
your company and so in my view being at
the gsb at the beginning of your
career is fabulous because the
difference between the good leaders that
we all
already are and the great leaders that
we hope to become
is emotional literacy and the ability to
celebrate diverse teams
and so i've been really excited to learn
that myself here and to be alongside
other peers who are deciding to do that
work too
and i'm incredibly excited that you guys
feel the same way um
so i'm honestly honored to be here it's
always great to be here with my partner
in crime carrie um and thank you will
for having us this is a really special
way to start the week
thank you all for joining us dean loving
carrie
emily thank you so much um i know y'all
have very busy days so we can go ahead
and take it from here
for everybody on this call this is an
invitation throughout the week we have
sessions
with faculty members with students with
admission staff
come with curiosity i encourage you to
definitely check out the stuff
that you're interested in but as folks
have been mentioning this is
about experiencing the world and
listening to the perspectives of those
around you
i'd highly encourage starting that
already this week and maybe checking out
a session or two
that might have not been on your radar
before this is a wonderful chance to
already get in that practice